alors que les bombes et les missiles
continuent de pleuvoir sur la région de
rerson les autorités ukrainiennes
ordonnent à tous les civils d'évacuer le
plus rapidement possible
cette nuit les agresseurs russes sont
tués un garçon de 6 ans dans la région
de Herson les jeunes doivent grandir
dans des conditions normales et pas sous
la canonade de l'artillerie russe c'est
pourquoi nous avons décidé d'évacuer
obligatoirement toutes les familles avec
des enfants des localités dangereuses
la ville de rerson est pourtant revenue
aux mains des troupes ukrainiennes en
novembre de l'année dernière obligeant
les forces russes à reculer au sud du
fleuve Nièvre mais Moscou contrôle
toujours de vastes étendues de
territoires dans la région et hymène des
campagnes de bombardements massive et
généralisé
75 bombardements ont récemment touché la
région en une seule journée selon les
autorités une pluie de bombe sous
laquelle tente de survivre les
populations civiles
on était dans l'appartement quand on a
entendu une grosse explosion
[Musique]
les conduites de gaz
les autorités régionales disent
également se préparer à des situations
d'urgence durant l'automne et l'hiver
notamment concernant l'approvisionnement
en électricité